[Music]
welcome thank you for joining me startup
Nation United this is a difficult a
difficult time we're we're recording
this on October 30th so it's 23 days
after and the turble events of October
7th um you know looking at it looking
what you guys are doing um with war room
at at the inag and generally your
program is is fantastic we we spoke
about a year ago on our podcast at 20
minute leaders in happier times but now
we're looking at the efforts that you've
been making as part of the this part of
the war and and supporting the ecosystem
at large and so we know this whole show
is about startup Nation United it's
about how wh an ecosystem came together
and are coming together during these
times of conflict and are supporting
each other I think that what you're what
you're doing um as a part of your
operation with the Israeli ecosystem and
companies is is really a sort of the the
a representation exactly of this of this
idea so I'm I'm really excited to to
hear a little bit about what you're
doing and and the impact that it's
having and will have and but and but
before we get started into that I I'd
love to hear a little bit about you know
who you who you are and what is the
negative what do you do in the
day-to-day outside of the conflict that
we have
Nowa yeah so uh hi so I'm Karina
Rubenstein I'm a venture partner for
Cent Tech in regular times and Nega and
regularly we invest in climate Tech and
so that's me in a
nutshell sh nice to meet you thank you
for hting us my name is Shar Levy and
I'm the marketing and Community manager
at hey I'm Amir regular times and the VP
of investment
in and do you need to explain a little
bit about or what K said
please and
please incubator governed by the is
innovation Authority we operate from the
south Vis thega region and we invest in
climate company between 1 million to1
million and a half dollars and we want
to promote a companies that have the
ability to expand and to grow in the sou
region of Israel we have nine portfolio
company
than 11 I think from today 11 from
today congratulations yeah happening
it's happening despite all we have 11
even even during the war
great see operating and wonderful well
um so so Shir I know that you've been
leading the efforts and the in in in
ne's response and to the larger Tech
ecosystem even beyond the neev where you
operate in the day today tell me a
little bit about where you were on
October 7th where where did this the the
the terrible events how did they meet
you so honestly I was away with my
friends for a weekend uh up north uh we
were just camping around having fun
enjoying the S holiday vacation and then
the morning of October 7 I went to watch
the watch the sun around he say I to and
uh all the that my sister told me she uh
was panick um and asked me to come home
as soon as possible then I had to wake
up my friends and we realized that we're
waking up in a different morning in our
country um we're still kind of
hesitating on trying to understand
whether or not should we move from the
north um down back to the um South area
of Israel where we live we live in sha
um so that was basically it but
eventually I went back home to my
parents so currently I'm at the center
is the hone wow and so they you know the
it the tragic events happened the attack
happened and you all sprang into action
I I'd love to understand what was the
sequence of events that transpired that
led to the formation of this operation
that you're running and walk me through
a little bit about you know the stories
of those days the founding of this
operation so if I can be completely
honest the first few days of uh after
the ti attack was a complete shock for
everyone of the team members and I think
we can speak on behalf of every Israeli
and Jew all over the world um we were
shocked we were sad we were hurt and mad
as we are still um and we try to figure
out how we can operate and help in the
circumstances of a war and then of
course as we are an incubator helping
startups um our startups employees
entrepreneurs and shers reach out to us
and told us that um they are recruited
back to the Army and we realized that we
need to help them as soon as possible so
we started within our incubator and
student enough we grew and collaborated
with iron Nation as well um we created
the form for are helping startups
mapping their knees and challenging
throughout the War uh trying to figure
out what they're facing what they will
be facing and what the situation
including human capital um and then as
soon as that started we started Market
it honestly and not in a very wide range
of marketing just around WhatsApp groups
and very very quickly it escalated to as
of now more than 200 companies that
reach out for help
um and that made us look in a more micro
level view to understand that we cannot
longer view only on the negative
ecosystem as we usually operate and we
have to elaborate and help and expand
our help to every single startup every
single entrepreneur in the Israeli
ecosystem uh to make sure every startup
will um maintain their momentum as soon
as the war is done and over and so what
what what have been some of the requests
or what what have you come to understand
that entrepreneurs and startups are in
need of you know in in a time like this
so most of the startups uh reach up to
us with the challenge of funding and
money which is kind of obvious because
of the um rising in hesitancy that
investors are kind of afraid to invest
in a very risk region as it is right now
in isra so most of them I think the more
than 90% of the request is the help of
getting money um whether or not it's
from VC or um or
donations uh but now as as we operate
the War Room uh we
are guiding them to figure out other
challenges so startups can come to us
and they do they come up to us and um
basically bring more challenges as for
example as
um the need of different place to work
at because they're relocated from their
home the need for different human
capital as most of their employes were
recruited for the Army um the need of
laptops and equipments in order to
operate and of course the need of
mentoring and um assistant in guidance
oneon-one and so what is the so how does
this how does this operation work you
mentioned before that you have different
Representatives who are are assigned to
different startups to really evaluate
their needs and to um be with them how
how how are you operationalizing this
because obviously I imagine that you
can't fulfill those requests yourself
right ER how so what what is the how do
you see this forming yeah so it starts
from a very easy application process in
our four and then our volunteer based
War rowing uh is basically every
volunteer gets to be an account manager
for a few startups uh he or she learns
the startup needs uh goes over the one
pager one liner understand their
challenges understand who are they
facing and then on a one-on-one
conversation or short meeting or email
they're um Gathering more challenges and
getting to know uh getting to know
better the the things that they can help
with with the that noise at the
end um and then the idea is basically to
make sure that every single person that
uh comes to our Center will have a
one-on-one guidance and mentorship
throughout the whole process until we're
done with the war and further more after
that I
assume it's important to that
we yeah no we looking Beyond uh uh
figuring out what they need right now uh
as a mapping stage but beyond that we
are you know collaborating with whoever
so a lot of
organizations uh and investors and
whatnot uh that can be of help and
assistance and also uh we we do
understand that you know for us to to
deal with it exclusively only us would
not have the impact on a national level
so and so we we are in a kind of a
recruitment phase a process now of of
gathering all kinds of collaborations
now um you know to to have a a better
offering from ourside or that are kind
of a hell process now right it sounds
like you there's there's a few pieces
that are that are important here that
you've you've uncovered first there's
that the understanding that there's a
gap now forming in the isra in the
startup Nation ecosystem and the Israel
ecosystem that there's many many
companies that are each going to have
different needs some of them are obvious
needs like funding to keep momentum and
to stay alive and but then there's the
not so obvious needs such as employee
displacement office infrastructure
different mechanisms which I'm sure
we're still not even aware of yet the
different challenges that now companies
and entrepreneurs will be facing in the
months to come even you know following
even the the the war and then then so
that there's the understanding phase
then you've operationalized now the sort
of the aggregation phase and providing a
platform for these companies to come and
and and and say okay we're here and we
understand that we need the support and
there is the phase of okay how do we
actually how do we provide this support
and some of it perhaps you can assist
with a lot of it you probably can't
because you have a job to do and you
have a fund and an incubator to run
which leads me to to my next question
how does this play out
with the fact that you have you know
you're an
organization you have your own mandate
your own roles and responsibilities the
war is also affecting you your families
your own group yet you've you've been
choosing to spend time and effort into
this talk to me a little bit about how
how this is playing out as an
organization now that you're choosing to
dedicate time and resources to this why
are you choosing to do this and and how
does this align with with what your day
to-day is like right this yeah and so to
be honest we are ecosystem players and
if we're looking at at the mro level we
looking at the the day that after it
will be after the war and we want people
to still have companies to go back to
and jobs to get back to and we
understand that this is the most
important thing we have to deal with
right now and in turn it will affect us
and our companies and our portfolio and
Duty and day to-day duties as well and
this is this is
what this is all ches right now if I
may and I guess that we can add it on a
personal level as an Israeli you have
the inner motivation to find a way to
help uh when your people are being hurt
slaughtered Etc as we know after we
suffered from this horic attack yes 100%
well uh I I want to thank you for
spending this time with me h i I know
how busy you are and very difficult
times you know we're recording this
October 30th so just 23 days after uh
the start of the war um and um and I'm
looking forward to seeing the the
positive impact that you're making and I
think the story of how you're bringing
together the you're engaging the
ecosystem at large and you're providing
a platform for E for the members of this
ecosystem to to make those requests and
then to now engage other members of the
ecosystem to to provide the support um I
I imagine it's going to be a big impact
and an entrepreneur I can obviously H
understand the different types of needs
that we have during this time um and I
think it's very cool how um you take a
your you know your focused on the
negative and you have your your mandate
and your focus area as an organization
but in light of what's happened it it
seems like it was almost intuitive for
all of you to expand beyond that for
this Mission and to to be a part of the
larger ecosystem which is really what
we're trying to show here in this in
this also so thank you uh very much for
joining me best of luck and make your
positive impact and thank you very much
thank you thank you for having
[Laughter]
us